[Applause]
i say organized because i prioritized
at least a list of top five things
amongst 20 i researched
that i wanted to talk to you about i
mean first of all we both
grew up you know um yes in a similar
job yep i mean you're
a true class act i had to figure some
stuff out along the way
but it's wonderful to share some
the fortune and privilege of having
longevity with you
yeah we both have been very lucky to to
be in an extraordinary position for a
long time which is really cool
i think that it takes a certain type
of diligence and
authenticity and being yourself but
figuring things out in front of people
knowing what to keep behind the scenes i
mean how have you navigated it
you know i got um extraordinarily lucky
to have a great mom
who really guided me um not only as a
person but a businesswoman
um because that's what you are even if
you're a kid you know in this business
you have to do that but i think for me i
always just had
a real i don't know understanding and
appreciation for
the fact that there are thousands and
millions of people in the world who
would give anything to get to do
what we do or or or have done what we've
done
and i always just felt a real
responsibility to not mess it up
like as much as possible and to continue
to have real gratitude for it every
single day like from the time that i
wake up until the time i go to bed i am
really grateful and and i know how
extraordinary it is the life that i've
been able to
to live and so i i just have tried to
treat it well because i think that
that's important
i totally agree and whenever i
made mistakes they were my mistakes
uh they were things i had to figure out
for myself
my mom and i did have an unorthodox
relationship we were both kind of
growing at the same time and figuring
things out and
as much as a million people would love
to have this job a million people would
love to have a great mom
and my mom i appreciate her to no end
because i wouldn't have the life i did
without her but
um your gratitude and humility i think
are at the forefront of everything you
just said as well
i i really believe that if you start
with gratitude
good things come to you you know and
things can unfold in a natural way
so i try to live by that as much as
possible and you do too i mean you
really give that to people and you teach
that to people and
i admire that very much thank you and
gosh everything you're saying i'm i'm
like
slack-jawed i'm just having so much
symmetry
with your lifestyle and choices and
intention i'm like
yes yes there was another story
that really stood out to me and i wanted
to ask you about it if it's okay
it has to do with when your daughter
heard you saying something about
yourself
yeah so you know you'll understand this
obviously too
um part of one of the things that we
deal with a lot in this business
is um you know having to be in front of
people when you feel good about yourself
when you don't
in your best moments and in your not so
good moments and then i've really spent
like the last probably
five years um really learning to just be
okay with where i am when i'm there
but this one particular afternoon i was
not feeling that way
it was i was not in my strength at that
moment and
i said something degrading about myself
and my parents and maybe what my weight
was or whatever
and i didn't know that my daughter had
heard it um
but later on she was like hey mommy um
you know you said something not so nice
about yourself
and i was like and it like instantly
kind of
like hit my heart in a in a in a really
strange
way because i was like oh no she heard
it you know and um
and i said yes i did and she said well
if you feel that way about yourself
and i look like you
do you feel that way about me too and i
was like
it literally i i took him and i was like
you know what mommy needs just a minute
and i went around the corner and i just
started like sobbing uncontrollably and
it was
the first moment as a mom of a daughter
that i realized
oh wow you know like i have a
responsibility that is that is
more profound and bigger than i even
possibly imagined and it is that
i have to be good to myself i have to be
kind to myself
because she's listening and she does
look like me and i do want her to grow
up and
and love herself in any moment because
she's her
you know and it really taught me
something very profound it was a big
changing moment for me
and ever since then i've been really
conscious about
what i say and what she knows that i
think about myself because i want her to
feel good about who she is
i mean i just really loved that story
i went into parenting with uh i found
out i had a daughter i was like
mother issues being relived karma i love
it
i found out i was having a second child
and she was a girl and i went
oh i understand i'm here on this planet
to raise girls i understand
and i felt such a responsibility
to take all those things that you and i
probably
had to navigate you know which side of
the tracks we fall on with all that
hollywood vanity you know
crapola that's so easy to get sucked up
into
and the fact that you didn't choose that
path that you have all that strength and
wisdom
that you had a moment she caught it you
cut yourself
boy i don't care where you grew up but
woman to woman mother to daughter
those moments will happen we will have
bad days we will
slip up we will watch our daughter
struggle
i thought you just handled that in such
an amazing way
and i took a lot from it because it's
something i'm very
cognizant of um but
when you hear other people's experience
with you know it gives you a lot more
objectivity and insights information
because we're all stuck in our own
brains we don't
have a ton of objectivity sometimes but
that story i really appreciate it no
thank you for sharing that because i
just
thought that was incredible